ANYTHING DEVELOPS.
>> THAT'S NOT.
I WANT TO BRING TOGETHER SOME
SEPARATE BITS OF NEWS ON
IMMIGRATION POLICY AND SHOW
YOU WHAT IT ADDS UP TO BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S A REALLY BIG
DEAL.
AFTER ALL THAT FUSS,
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, WHATEVER,
WE LEARN THAT THE WALL IS
BEING BUILT.
60 MILES ARE DONE.
AS ALWAYS I WILL SAY I AM PRO-
IMMIGRATION.
I'M AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF AND MY
PARENTS.
I HOPE I WILL SOON BE A
CITIZEN.
I THINK THE VAST AMOUNT OF
AMERICANS ARE PRO- IMMIGRATION
AS LONG AS IT IS PROPERLY
CONTROLLED.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS ARE
COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO GIVE SANCTUARY TO THOSE
FLEEING PROSECUTION AS LONG AS
THAT IS AUTHENTIC.
THAT GOES FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS,
DECENT PEOPLE WHO JUST WANT
THE BEST FOR THE COUNTRY AND
ARE SICK OF BEING SMEARED IS
RACIST FOR SUPPORTING
IMMIGRATION POLICIES WHICH,
LET ME REMIND YOU WERE ONCE
WIDELY HELD BY DEMOCRATS.
LET'S PICK A COUPLE OF RANDOM
DEMOCRATS.
HOW ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND CHUCK
SCHUMER.
[INAUDIBLE]
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS WRONG,
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
UNTIL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CONVINCED WE WILL STOP FUTURE
FLOWS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
WE WILL MAKE NO PROGRESS ON
DEALING WITH THE MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WERE HERE
NOW AND ON RATIONALIZING OUR
SYSTEM OF LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
IT'S PLAIN AND SIMPLE AND
UNAVOIDABLE.
>> WHO COULD POSSIBLY DISAGREE
WITH THAT.
>> WE CAN'T WALL OURSELVES OFF
TO THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE NOT
BOUND BY BORDERS.
THE THREAT OF COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE LEGS ECO, DRUG
TRAFFICKING, CLIMATE CHANGE NO
WALL CAN BE BUILT THEMATIC IT
IS A SHAME THAT THIS PRESIDENT
WHO IS PLUNGING THE NATION
INTO CHAOS IS THROWING ANOTHER
TEMPER TANTRUM AND WILL HURT
LOTS OF INNOCENT PEOPLE.
THE TRUMP TIM
THE TRUMP TEMPER TANTRUM
MAY PRODUCE A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
IT WILL NOT GET HIM HIS WALL.
>> BIDEN SAID NO WILL
>> BIDEN SAID NO WALL CAN
BE BUILT.
HE WAS SO SERIOUS.
[INAUDIBLE]
BOTH OF THEM VOTED FOR THE
2006 SECURE FENCE ACT.
BOTH OF THEM HAVE MORE MONEY
IN IT THEN TRUMPS.
THEY'RE BOTH AGAINST IT.
[INAUDIBLE]
IT'S THE SAME IT IDIOCY.
THEY'VE LIFTED AN INJUNCTION
ON A NEW RULE WHICH REQUIRES
ASYLUM-SEEKERS TO CLAIM ASYLUM
IN THE FIRST SAFE COUNTRY THEY
COME TO RATHER THAN TRAVEL
THROUGH COUNTRIES BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO GET TO AMERICA IN
CLAIM ASYLUM HERE.
THE DEMOCRATS LOST THEIR MIND
THE SUPREME COURT'S DECISION
TO ALLOW THEM.
[INAUDIBLE]
IT'S DEEPLY DISAPPOINTING FOR
FAMILY DANGERS AND A CLEAR
DEPARTURE FROM U.S. AND
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO
RIDICULOUS.
IT BRINGS US IN LINE WITH IT.
DO THEY EVEN KNOW THIS NEW
TRUMP ASYLUM POLICY IS
BASICALLY THE SAME AS THE EU'S.
OF COURSE PEOPLE WANT TO COME
HERE BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN
ORDERLY PROCESS.
IT DEPENDS ON GOVERNMENT
CONTROL OF IMMIGRATION.
WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT HERE SINCE
AT LEAST 1986 WHEN PRESIDENT
REAGAN SIGNED THE REFORM AND
CONTROL ACT WHICH DID THE
EXACT OPPOSITE.
GUATEMALA JUST VOTED IN A NEW
PRESIDENT.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY THOSE
COUNTRIES ARE CORRUPT.
YES THEY ARE, BUT NOT AS
CORRUPT AS WASHINGTON WHERE
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN BRIBES FROM
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IN THE
FORM OF PAYMENTS OR WHERE DICK
CHENEY ENGINEERED A WAR THAT
FUNNELED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO THE COMPANY WHERE HE WAS
CEO FOR OUR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE FUNDED BY THE
EXACT SAME BUSINESSES THEY
REGULATE.
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THAT
SCANDAL LATER.
GUESS WHAT THE SAME GAINS ARE
HERE.
THEY HAVE TOTALLY LOST THE
PLOT ON IMMIGRATION.
THEY'VE LOST TOUCH WITH
WORKING AMERICANS.
IT'S NOT THEIR JOBS BEING LOST
, THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
FINALLY PUTTING TOGETHER THE
REASONABLE, COHERENT
IMMIGRATION POLICY THIS
COUNTRY HAS BEEN CRYING OUT
FOR.
NEARLY 50 YEARS.
WE SEE IT WITH THE WALL GOING
UP BUT IT'S MUCH MORE THAN
THAT.
THERE'S A TECHNOLOGY WALL,
ENTITLEMENT FORM WALL AND A
FOREIGN POLICY WAR.
AS WE SAW WITH IMMEDIATE
RESULTS WITH MEXICO.
ON TOP OF ALL THAT AND TOTALLY
CONTRADICTING THE
ESTABLISHMENT LIE THAT THIS IS
A XENOPHOBIC RESTRICTION OF
APPROACH.
THESE ARE WALLS WITH THE
DOOR.
MONTHS AGO THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED A PLAN NOT CUT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION BUT TO KEEP IT AND
REFORMAT TO BECOME A
MERIT-BASED SYSTEM.
IT'S UTTERLY REASONABLE AND IN
LINE.
THE DEMOCRATS LURCHED AND IT'S
AN EXTREMIST POSITION.
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK OF ALL
THAT.
>> LET ME SAY THIS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT SITUATION
THAT HAPPENED OVER THE LAST
WEEK WAS THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION ON ASYLUM.
IT DOES SO MUCH MORE THAN WHAT
HAD HAPPENED IN THE PAST.
BUILDING A WALL IS JUST PART
OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE ASYLUM LAW, TO BE ABLE TO
ENFORCE THAT AS A DETERRENT.
I'VE BEEN THERE SO MANY TIMES,
I'VE BEEN IN GUATEMALA TWICE
THIS YEAR, I'VE BEEN ON THE
BORDER AND I KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON.
THE DRUG CARTELS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS USE THESE LAWS TO
BRING MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
IN.
MANY ARE COMING HERE FOR
BETTER JOBS BUT LET ME BE
FAIR, I WAS IN GUATEMALA AND
IN A LOT OF THESE DIFFERENT
VILLAGES AND TALKING TO THE
GUATEMALAN GOVERNMENT.
I WAS ON THE GROUND.
THERE ARE ISSUES WITH GANGS
AND THEY WERE TOLD, THEY WERE
ACTUALLY REHEARSING ON THE WAY
TO THE BORDER WHAT THEY WOULD
NEED TO SAY TO GET INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
SAY THAT YOU ARE CLEAN GANGS,
BUT YOU'RE PART OF A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, THAT YOU CAN'T
RETURN FOR POLITICAL REASONS
AND THEN WE THOUGHT SPREAD TO
THE CHILDREN, BRING YOUR
CHILDREN AND YOU'LL GET SAFE
HARBOR IN THE USA DOMICILE
QUALIFIED TO AFRICA AND OTHER
NATIONS WERE PEOPLE WERE
SAYING LOOK, IF WE MAKE THESE
SAME CONDITIONS TO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES WE WILL BE ABLE
TO GET IN AND THAT IS A HUGE
PROBLEM AND IT'S A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE RIGHT THING
AND SO THAT THE SUPREME
COURT.
>> WHEN I SEE THAT VIDEO OF
NANCY AND CHUCK AND JOE BIDEN
AND THEIR IMMIGRATION VIEWS
FROM LESS THAN TEN YEARS AGO,
MY FAKE EYELASHES ALMOST FELL
OFF BECAUSE I WAS ROLLING MY
EYES SO HARD.
ARE YOU GUYS SERIOUS?
IT'S ON TAPE.
THIS IS WHY WE CAN'T GET
ANYTHING DONE WITH
IMMIGRATION.
IT'S A PARTISAN ISSUE.
NOT REALLY BASED ON LOGIC OR
REASON OR HOW EACH PARTY FEELS
PRIDE IT'S BASED ON THE
OPPOSITE POSITION TO TAKE SO I
CAN RUN ON THIS AND RUN A
CAMPAIGN ON THIS.
PEOPLE ARE SO FED UP.
I LIKE TO THINK OF MYSELF AS
KIND OF A TYPICAL NORMAL
AMERICAN.
I'M AN IMMIGRANT AS WELL, I'M
CANADIAN AND I'M FED UP.
I DON'T HAVE MUCH MORE TO GIVE.
>> THE THING IS, THAT CHUCK
SCHUMER TAPE THAT WE PLAYED,
IN THAT SAME SPEECH, WE COULD
JUST RUN THE WHOLE THING.
ANOTHER PART OF IT, REALLY
SIGNIFICANT RIGHT HE WAS
TALKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, THE
ECONOMIC MIGRANTS IN THE
IMPACT ON LOW WAGE MIGRATION
AND WE HAVE TO STOP IT BECAUSE
IT HURTS MIGRATION, LET'S KNOW
THAT ELECTIONS HAVE
CONSEQUENCES IN DONALD TRUMP
AND MITCH MCCONNELL ARE
FRUSTRATED BUT THEY ARE
PASSING ALL THE NOMINATIONS OF
THE PRESIDENT, PUTTING THEM IN
PLACES IN THE COURTS MATTER.
WERE NOT OPPOSED, WE JUST WANT
AN ORDERLY PROCESS.
IF YOU COME THERE AND YOU GET
TO MEXICO YOU HAVE TO STOP AND
YOU HAVE TO APPLY TO GET INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
THEY'RE COMING ACROSS RIVERS
AND IT WAS JUST A MAD FLOOD.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY RINGING
BELLS AND HAVING BORDER PATROL
PICK UP IN DIFFERENT AREAS
AROUND THE BORDER.
IT'S THE MOST INSANE THING.
TICKETS UP AND GIVE US A RIDE,
OPEN BORDER PATROL STATION.
IF YOU CAN MAKE THAT CLAIM AND
GET INTO THE COUNTRY, IF YOU
DON'T YOU'LL BE TURNED DOWN,
THE DEMOCRAT CONVENTION WAS
GONNA BE IN MILWAUKEE
WISCONSIN.
WHAT YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO BUILD AROUND THAT
CONVENTION?
A WALL.
>> YOU'LL NEED A TICKET TO GET